you  I'm glad I got in that car with you all  cameras  iMacs and transformers partnership  started ten years ago with the first  transformers and the partnership has  gotten more traction throughout each one  imax gives me the tools to give you the  best cinema experience in the world  transformers has been a giant part of  our brand it helped build imax Michael's  pushed us to be more nimble therefore  smaller but not to compromise resolution  he's pushed us for the 3d to be more  seamless  is constantly trying to surge the  filmmaking experience  give me greedy here  on this movie transformers last night we  are shooting with IMAX 3d and the  results are phenomenal Michael is the  very first filmmaker to take two of  these cameras and configure them on a 3d  rig and shoot in 3d in real time and  that's not trivial the resolution the  detail the clarity it really is  mind-boggling we are using all the IMAX  technology to give you the best  experience you will see this year  you  you